well every year fireworks scare hundreds
of pets causing them to bolt from their
homes leaving many pet owners scrambling
to find their furry family members the
day after the fourth and for days after
mary jane bellies is live at the animal
foundation where you can get some help
finding your lost pet mary jane we heard
some little barkers behind you earlier
are they
are you seeing some animals in there
this morning that might be runaways
oh sherry absolutely we are and you know
the animal foundation tells us that the
day after the fourth and into the next
couple of days will be a busy one for
them as they try to reunite these furry
pets with their owners and i'm joined
really early this morning with kelsey
peasy with the animal foundation kelsey
thank you so much for joining us you
know we talked a lot about how you guys
are really going to still keep seeing
some pets come in and the most important
part right now is for people to help you
guys by adopting pets so you guys can
make room for more animals that's right
and larger pets are probably larger dogs
are in need of the most help you know
small puppies smaller dogs kittens they
really only spend a day or two in our
adoption center before they're adopted
but larger pups just like chickalito
here he's been here over 90 days they
wait a lot longer to find their forever
families weeks sometimes even months
wow and you know we were talking earlier
too that it's sometimes hard because pet
owners they may not always come to the
animal foundation to pick up their pets
so sometimes you have some animals that
are here for days even up to weeks
yeah if you if your pet is missing we
really urge you to look at our website
our lost and found page you'll see
pictures of all of our lost pets it's
updated every couple of hours but more
importantly check your neighborhood
usually pets do not get that far and one
of your neighbors might have taken in
your pet you can post photos of your pet
on next door there are other avenues to
try and track down your pet perfect well
kelsey thank you so much and again the
animal foundation is waiving reclaim
fees up until july 10. reporting live
mary jane balleza live local now